he showed us the whole house he showed us the
place where he has his 27 honoris
causa and I asked him doctor frank
which of all these diplomas
he feels happiest with or the one he
feels most proud of and curiously he
told us that of  one who says only flight
I say a gentleman like these indices only
plate
then he talked to us but tasty
like a name to taste he was a good
talker really he says to taste he told us
how he went to learn in classes
and the third time he came out alone in the  airplane
said how could I do that yes it was a
great feat not
when they are in the auditorium it is that he
was really so close such a friend they
made things so easy he explained
very easily his books are more complicated
frankel's books are not easy to
read but he  when he spoke he was
inspiring if in a conversationalist he had
everything to convince something that i think
is that víctor frankl never imagined the
importance that his logotherapy would have
in mexico
every day  more people know him, more people
respect him, more people admire him because he was
ahead of our time, he went ahead
to say that there was a triad that
we would have to be careful about, such as
aggression, depression and addiction, I
don't think that right
now in Mexico we are in need of
him and that is why logo education is to
prevent people who do not live
after the need for a
therapeutic intervention everything is because victor frankl
in his beginnings was an educator logo
when he worked with young people and what he
taught and from there return to us  to
do precisely this because I
consider him an educator apart from an
educator,
a trainer yes and also a very
conciliatory person what I have heard from
him for example when he went to visit the
prisoners in San Quentin and the way
he spoke to them having  he has also been a
prisoner he
was really admirable a
generous hearted people